bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo compagne de
michaël szames oeuf mon genre mais
quelle l'actualité cette semaine il ya
bien eu sur rue le mariage pour tous en
débat à l'assemblée la ministre
christiane taubira affrontés toute la
semaine les foudres de l'opposition qui
a déposé plus de cinq mille amendements
nuits blanches en perspective
normalement jusqu'au 10 février et vote
prévu le 12 pour pimenter un petit peu
plus le départ circulaire signée
christiane taubira prévoit la
naturalisation des enfants mais à
l'étranger d'une gestation pour autrui
time in maladroit en tout cas
l'opposition s'est engouffrée dans la
brèche
enfin il y aura bien une réforme
constitutionnelle était prochain réforme
du statut pénal du chef de l'état et
peut-être aussi vote des étrangers
le premier ministre jean-marc ayrault ne
l'a pas exclu il consultera les partis
politiques sur la question est avec nous
pour commenter tous des sujets
d'actualité christian jacob bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président des
députés ump depuis 2010 le moins que
l'on puisse dire évidemment c'est que
vous êtes sur la brèche matin midi soir
week-end compris sur ce texte sur le
mariage pour tous on vous pose juste une
petite question ça va vous tenez le coup
postez vous inquiétez pas on tient bien
le coup
d'accord alors vas avant de dérouler
toute l'actualité de la semaine
entendre quelques députés pour savoir ce
qu'ils pensent de vous écouter et
regarder moi j'ai plaisir à travailler
avec lui il a un parcours est un
parcours républicain intéressant des
responsabilités qu'il a acquise ailleurs
et pour autant ils essayent de faire le
grand méchant quelquefois
haussant la voix en faisant des mises en
cause ça ne lui réussit pas totalement
donc voilà il ferait mieux d'être
lui-même tout le temps c'est quelqu'un
de très sérieux
alors que beaucoup ne le prennent pas au
sérieux il faut jamais oublier que le
passé de christian jacob plaide pour lui
ça a été un président et un syndicaliste
redouté et redoutable et donc
tous ceux qui comme toujours ont
beaucoup de mépris pour les gens qui ne
sont pas du sérail ne le prennent pas à
haut niveau qui devrait être le sien
alors parce qu'il est ancré dans le réel
et parce qu'il nous a tellement reproché
à nous la gauche souvent faire
l'opposition systématique d'être dans la
caricature la posture quand est-ce que
lui en tant que chef du groupe ump
va-t-il sortir de la posture de la
caricature le groupe qu'il préside parce
que ça devient fatigant et ça ne fait
pas forcément avancer la démocratie
c'est vrai ça christian jacob
on ne vous prend pas assez au sérieux
dit lionnel luca m'écoutais je sais pas
donc c'était une remarque très
sympathique la pared de luire l ucad
c'est vrai que je viens pas du sérail
c'est vrai que j'ai un parcours qui est
un peu atypique dans le lot dans le
dans le milieu d'un milieu politique
vous a été ou pas au départ c'est plutôt
un handicap mais après
vous savez on peut on peut aussi en
anjou et retourner les retourner les
arguments c'est à dire que ça permet de
ne jamais être là on vous attend et
finalement ça m'a plutôt porté chance
sur le parcours qui est le mien que ce
soit pour les deux élections successives
la présidence du groupe pour les trois
responsabilités ministérielles que j'ai
pu occuper ou présider une commission à
l'assemblée donc
bon je m'en accommode plutôt village et
entendu razzy hammadi qui parle de
caricature est ce que vous pensez que
pour se faire entendre dans l'hémicycle
notamment et pour porter le message
politique il faut toujours un peu
caricaturée je sais pas je pense pas que
le mot caricatures sur celui qui
convient mais c'est vrai que le
président de président de groupe
de fait d'une part le premier rôle c'est
de maintenir la cohésion dans le groupe
c'est aussi de faire en sorte notamment
lorsqu'on est dans l'opposition que les
droits de l'opposition soient respectés
donc ça oblige effectivement à monter le
temps régulièrement parce que la
majorité a toujours tendance à vouloir
enrichir caricaturer un titre non non
mais c'est pour ça je pense pas que
caricature soit le le bon mot mais il
faut forcer le trait parce que parce
qu'il faut défendre les droits de
l'opposition et toute majorité qu'elle
soit objectivement de droite comme de
gauche a toujours tendance à essayer de
minimiser les droits de l'opposition
donc il faut se faire entendre dans la
petite question on a vu cette semaine
est passée de syndicalisme dans ce
domaine c'est plutôt ça nous a aidés
effectivement une dernière petite
question il ya une proposition
écologiste qui a pas dû vous échapper
cette semaine qu'ils demandent
l'autorisation d'une coprésidence de
groupe et devra l'obtenir d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à partager
votre présidence de groupe pense qu on
est là dans la caricature ccbc pour le
coup de allemand c'est ce que
veulent les socialistes c'est à dire
c'est c'est un bureau plus une voiture
une bon voilà on reconnaît bien les
verts là où ils sont habituellement rey
a partagé l'éco prêt non parce que un
moment il y en a un qui siège en
conférence des présidents et donc lequel
va siéger en conférence des présidents à
tour de rôle et si vous avez deux
présidents deux coprésidents qu'un avis
divergent c'est ingérable
donc tout ça ça fait de sa fait de
l'image ça fait un peu de buzz mais
concrètement ça ne peut pas fonctionner
parce qu'à un moment il y en a un qui
décide et qui siège en commission
en conférence des présidents ou ou qui
préside le groupe il faut rendre les
arbitrages et autrement lorsqu'il ya
désaccord entre deux coprésidents le
fait comment à pile ou face
j choisir des présidents qui a priori
sont plutôt un peu complémentaire
oui enfin je suis pas persuadé que j'ai
tout un modèle de fonctionnement là
c'est moi contre de bon fonctionnement
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire vous
n'êtes pas partants allez on va
commencer avec le mariage pour tous bien
sûr marathon parlementaire c'est parti
deux semaines de débats prévus dans
l'hémicycle week-end compris c'est
christiane taubira cette semaine qui est
monté au créneau pour défendre le texte
escarmouches garantie en voici un
échantillon
nous sommes mercredi soir lors de la
discussion générale et c'est thibault le
floch qui nous relate la science pour
184 contre 298 la mention elle n'est pas
adoptée
il y aura donc pas de référendum sur le
mariage pour tous 1 faute sans surprise
notamment pour laurent wauquiez qui
avait déposé cette motion référendaire
quelques instants plus tôt il tenait ces
propos à destination des parlementaires
de la majorité
vous ne nous condamnerait pas par vos
brevets bien pensante au silence vous ne
condamnerait pas au silence les députés
qui dépose cette motion
vous ne condamnerait pas au silence les
millions de français qui partage nos
inquiétudes et auquel nous voulons par
le référendum que la parole leur soit
rendue
selon l'article 11 de la constitution
seuls les sujets sociaux peuvent être
soumis à un référendum pour laurent
wauquiez
cette règle s'applique également pour
les sujets sociétaux comme le mariage
pour tous pour contrer cet argument le
président de la commission des lois va
alors faire appel à quelques manuels de
droit constitutionnel
par exemple celui ci laissant un mot de
la démocratie pas mal il a été publié
chez odile jacob
à cette question les réformes de société
relève terre et des réformes sociales de
la nation dans l'article 11 h 444 les
auteurs répondent non ses auteurs c'est
raphaël hadas lebel laurent wauquiez la
garde des sceaux elle ne s'est pas
attardé sur ce point constitutionnelle
ce qui l'a surtout interpellé dans le
discours de laurent wauquiez
c'est lorsque celui-ci évoqué l'intérêt
de l'enfant et j'ai dit que oui
reste hypocrite de faire semblant de ne
pas voir ces familles homoparentales et
ses milliers d'enfants qui sont exposés
au regard social réprobateur ils ont
vous nous parler des effets
psychologiques sur les enfants mais les
et égyptologie ils ont d'abord sur le
regard social
ils ont d'abord sur la discrimination
ils ont d'abord sur le rejet
ils ont d'abord c'est le revenu une
citoyenneté alors oui nous le refusons
la motion référendaire et en rejeter le
débat général sur le projet de loi peut
désormais reprendre dans une ambiance
qui promet de rester électrique alors
cette fameuse motion référendaire qui
renvoyait un référendum qui donc a été
rejetée c'est vous qui l'avez déposé
elle a été défendue par laurent wauquiez
c'était un bon choix parce que monsieur
revault à sa était un peu malin il est
allé découvrir un texte où le rock est
dit on l'a entendu pas de me pas de
référendum sur un sosie c'est un sujet
de société
oui mais c'est plus qu'un sujet de
société selon l'article 11 prévoit que
ce soit sur les sujets sociaux on est
directeur n'est sur un vrai sujet social
puisque à partir du moment où on ouvre
le droit au mariage et surtout à
l'adoption aux couples homosexuels
il y a des conséquences sociales
directes et donc l'argumentation
constitutionnel de dossiers talent joue
un peu sur les mots mais j'ai deux
sociétés le mari oui d'accord mais enfin
c'est les conséquences aussi social
concerne l'ensemble de la population et
donc on est aussi sur un sujet social
l'argument constitutionnel ne tient pas
soit le président de la république
souhaite consulter les français par
référendum soit il a peur la réaction
des français sur un point de rennes un
homme celles qui ne l'étaient pas oui
mais parce que le président de la
république a peur de la réaction de
l'opinion
ce que je peux comprendre puisque quand
on voit la difficulté qui a toujours en
france avec les référendums c'est que
souvent les français synthèse répondre
d'abord à celui qui pose la question
plutôt qu'à la question posée donc ce
qui fait pour monsieur hollande de
raison d'avoir peur
le bisou le bilan de son action depuis
six mois
fake vraisemblablement les français lui
répondrait par la négative et ensuite
sur le fond moi je suis convaincu que
les français répondrais non notamment
sur le sujet de l'adoption avec la
gestation pour autrui la procréation
mères des questions très très courte
il y aura d'autres manifestations je
pense il y en un samedi de deux prévus
et dans les villes de province est
vraisemblablement en tout cas moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait une autre grande
manifestation sont légitimes et vous le
nombre de députés ump qui voteront pour
ou qu'ils s'abstiendront sur ce texte
il faut attendre la fin des débats
d'abord est ce que on arrive à modifier
le texte par voie d'amendement donc
attendant qu'il soit voté moi j'ai
toujours dit qu'il y aurait entre 5 et
10% du groupe qui pourrait soit soit
voté soit ça veut dire non mais on a
toujours le faire moi j'ai toujours eu
ce souci vous parliez tout à l'heure mon
ont passé syndical de faire en sorte que
chaque avis puis s'être entretenu
entendu moi je compte beaucoup sur le le
débat je pense que c'est important
d'avoir le débat y compris dans nos
formations politiques
c'est pour ça que je suis en désaccord
par exemple avec franck riester sera
position sur le texte mais j'ai fait en
sorte que franck riester puisse
s'exprimer
avec avec un temps de parole important
en début de discussion générale et je
regrette qu'elle mon collègue socialiste
bruno le roux interdisent de temps de
parole ses collègues qui ne partagent
pas son avis il va même plus loin les
menaces même à l'investiture au temps d
écouter christian jacob vous allez
l'entendre bruno le roux au sujet des
amendements qui sont parfois sérieux et
d'autre un petit peu moins écoutés quand
on veut enlever l'âge légal pour se
marier permettre les mariages à
l'intérieur d'une même famille
des stigmatiser les outre-mer en disant
que dans ces départements il faudrait
désigner les officiers d'état civil
parce que les mères il serait plus
opposé qu'ailleurs le fait que le
mariage introduirait un appel d'air et
qu'il faut donc contrôler les flux
d'homosexuels venant de l'étranger
il ya toute une série d'amendements qui
montre bien qu'un certain nombre de
députés
en tout cas selon les situations à ne
pas vouloir beaucoup de sérénité dans ce
débat
enfin qu'il dit obstruction
parlementaire l'obstruction c'est quand
la gauche dépose 140 mille amendements
sur le texte sur l'énergie 138000
exactement là il ya cinq mille
amendements de dépose lecture tous en
prennent pas très sérieux ces
amendements la plupart du temps et
souvent ils permettent d'avoir une
accroche c'est ça aussi d'un amendement
pour pouvoir exprimer à l'oral dans
l'hémicycle la position qui est qui qui
est celle de chacun des députés et le
droit fondamental d'un député c'est de
pouvoir déposer des amendements et le
reproche que je fais à à bruno le roux
ses dettes dans ce mais c'est pas lui en
tant que tel mais c'est la logique très
sectaire du ps vous rendez compte
les gens qui ne sont pas de l'avis du
président du groupe sont interdits de
parole dans l'hémicycle programmée c'est
dire que dans la discussion générale
c'est le ou dans l'émotion c'est le
président de groupe qui attribue qui
désigne les orateurs et là monsieur
l'euro les députés socialistes et on l'a
vu il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
opposés à ce texte sont interdits depuis
ouverte à ce stade oui ils sont
interdits de temps de parole ils sont
menacés sur leur investiture
enfin les calades interne d'une aide en
sept c'est un rôle dans l'hémicycle
c'est ça qui est important à ce que vous
avez le temps de parole parce que disait
qu'il n'y avait pas cinq bars attendait
encore on à l'assemblée nationale bon
excusez nous déranger vous pourrez aussi
vous dire vous êtes de l'opposition
désolé mais aller voir ailleurs on
réserve l'hémicycle aux députés le câble
vous reconnaissez quand même ce mérite
là à bruno l'euro de ne pas avoir imposé
de temps programmé
ça n'est pas du tout un brouillon l'euro
n'est pas du tout bruno lo c'est la
conférence des présidents qui décide si
on applique le temps programmé ou pas
d'ailleurs le temps programmé permet
aussi par exemple sur la discussion
générale d'avoir plus de temps donc ça
aurait pu être un autre choix qui était
fin ça aurait permis aussi avoir
davantage de temps puisque le temps
programmé on peut on a aussi la
possibilité de demander un temps plus
longue que chaque groupe à ce qu'on
appelle la droite tirage sur un débat
d'au moins 50 heures donc on aurait
utilisé ce droit de tirage donc je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de facilité qui ont été
faites la vaisselle est ce que vous
estimez que l'ump là a une chance de se
refaire un peu une santé après ce que
vous avez subi il ya quelques jours
quelques semaines s'est pas d'abord ce
n'est pas le sujet et ensuite on est sur
un sur un vrai bouleversement bioéthique
avec ce débat et et avec ce texte
et c'est pour ça que il ya une telle
mobilisation
le sujet c'est pas de règle et dire nous
les tensions internes qu'on a eu au
moins deux mois de décembre d'ailleurs
l'ordre du jour c'est pas nous qui
décidons
c'est le gouvernement c'est le
gouvernement qui impose ce texte oui
mais un moment où on a un plan social
qui tombe chaque jour
la préoccupation du gouvernement qui est
de mettre ce texte à l'ordre du jour de
parler ensuite du droit de vote des
étrangers d'aller ensuite sur les
intrigues et c'est moi sur ce texte
le risque vraiment profond c'est les
bouleversements bioéthique sans avoir le
courage de l'assumer et le reproche que
je fais au gouvernement c'est vraiment
ce manque de courage cette malhonnêteté
intellectuelle c'est de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
si vous me permettez de prendre deux
exemples pour bien expliquer ou et où il
ya malhonnêteté intellectuelle
par exemple sur la procréation
médicalement assistée
elle est autorisée aujourd'hui pour des
raisons elle est autorisée
oui oui non mais c'est là qu'il ya c'est
malhonnête c'est une vraie malhonnêteté
intellectuelle puisque elle décline
obligatoirement de ce texte
mais comme il fallait consulter le
comité national d'éthique
et que le gouvernement a peur de la
réaction du comité national d'éthique
donc du coup on vend le texte par
appartement c'est à dire qu'on le
renvoie à nos textes donc on trompe les
français avec ce texte
et c'est la même chose sur la gestation
pour autrui
alors on vient tout petit peu la
discussion générale qui a donné lieu
parfois des échanges un peu surréaliste
un exemple dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi et nous avons vu refleurir des
discours aux relents homophobes qui sont
indignes à ceux qui seraient tentés par
cette aventure je dis ici le temps du
triangle rose est terminée
notre rôle de législateur est tout autre
il est de servir l'égalité et le bien
commun par la règle commune qu'est la
loi
nous venons d'entendre parler de
triangles roses nous condamnons
absolument l'homophobie
nous condamnons absolument les actes
inqualifiables qui ont été accomplis par
le régime nazi à l'encontre dès
personnes homosexuelles mais il n'est
pas acceptable est les mesures vielles
que vous alliez porter à d'autres
rencontres des critiques de cette
nature-là bon formule contre formule on
est un peu loin du débat de fond pour
mai contre formule les propos tenus par
le député socialiste sont des propos
imbéciles les propos imbéciles parler du
triangle rose faire référence ce à quoi
il a fait référence c'est scandaleux
c'est vraiment c'est ce sont des propos
d'ewald non oui là enfin on n'est pas
obligé de tenir de tels propos imbéciles
à la tribune de l'assemblée
vous parliez de la gpa on en a beaucoup
entendu parler avant l'examen de ce
texte sur le mariage et puis voilà on
entend encore parler il fait son
apparition de nouveau cette semaine avec
une circulaire signée par christiane
taubira voici les explications de jean
baptiste daoulas
c'est une nouvelle polémique qui pleut
sur christiane taubira à peine sortie du
conseil des ministres
la garde des sceaux doit réaffirmer sa
position sur la gpa
il n'y a pas la moindre motif
la position n'est pas mon autorité ni du
gouvernement
c'est le cas de nice ni de moi
personnellement il n'y a pas la moindre
modification sur la gpa une mise au
point qui ne suffit pas à l'opposition à
l'assemblée jean françois copé
s'inquiète des conséquences de la
circulaire elle a pour conséquence de
reconnaître en droit français la
validation de la validité de la
gestation pour autrui réalisés à
l'étranger
il ne s'agit pas d'une circulaire si on
l'état civil c'est une circulaire sur un
constat de nationalité en clair la
circulaire ne change rien à la filiation
elle se contente d'accorder la
nationalité française aux enfants nés
d'une mère porteuse à l'étranger
la gpa reste interdite en france mais
l'opposition n'est toujours pas
convaincu
une deuxième question identique est
posée au gouvernement soit la position
du gouvernement et pour les mères
porteuses pour la gestation pour autrui
et il faut le préciser
soit vous êtes content et à ce moment là
il faut aussi monsieur le premier
ministre est beaucoup plus claire mes
chers collègues c'est le gouvernement
qui décide du ministre chargé de la
réponse
l'ambiance est électrique l'opposition
réclamait jean marc ayrault s'est à
nouveau
christiane taubira qui répond j'avoue
que il me faudra faire quelques efforts
pour m'habituer à la nécessité de
répéter constamment exactement les mêmes
réponses aux mêmes questions
donc le gouvernement reste opposée à la
gpa
nous vous le répéterons aussi souvent
que nécessaire et cette circulaire
concerne onze enfants tous mais l'ump
n'en démord pas la circulaire ouvre une
brèche très dangereuse
généraliser la procréation médicale
assistée à tous les couples on va
généraliser on va autoriser les
généraliser les mères porteuses
voilà la gpda au coeur du débat sur le
mariage pour tous
même si le texte ne prévoit absolument
pas de la réforme est alors que tu as
comme j'ai une petite image à vous
proposer se déroule le 16 janvier
dernier en commission des lois
écoutez christiane taubira j'ai fait
préparer une circulaire qui va partir
qui est déjà prête un don qui va partir
qui s'adresse aux tribunaux d'instance
pour faciliter la la délivrance de
certificat de nationalité française
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'éléments de
droit qui justifie qu'on a hâte qu'on ne
donne pas de certificat de nationalité
française à ces enfants qui sont
français
dans la vision que j'ai de la loi si par
malheur alors vous voyez bien que hervé
mariton est présent ça se déroule le 16
janvier dernier en commission des lois
vous ne pouvez pas dire que vous n'étiez
pas au courant de cette circulaire que
sur jacob mais j'ai noté que la ministre
elle-même dit qu'elle n'est pas au
courant puisque nous mais elle d'abord
elle n'est absolument pas référence à la
gestation pour autrui
ensuite ce qui est grave c'est le fond
c'est-à-dire que l'on valide n'envahit
pas le fait d'apprendre simplement par
le journal tout est ce que j'ai vu dans
un grand journal du soir ils font dans
un grand journal du soir c'est que la
ministre est surprise qu'elle sorte
la circulaire sorte un site son
administration je pense qu'elle aurait
préféré un autre calendrier mais peu
importe tout cela c'est le fond qui est
grave c'est que l'on valide la gpa à
l'étranger c'est-à-dire en clair pour
ceux qui ont les moyens de dépenser
entre 80 et 100 mille dollars pour payer
pour louer un ventre à l'étranger c'est
à peu près le coût d'une d'une gestation
pour autrui aux etats unis 80 100 mille
dollars
pour eux il n'y a pas de problème donc
on reconnaît en revanche en france alors
là on dit soyez rassurés mon bon peuple
surtout en france il n'y aura jamais de
l'égalisation les cas ce week-end vous
parle ce sont 44 cas qu'il s'agit
simplement de faciliter la délivrance de
la carte d'identité pour des français à
des enfants dont le père
dans les français c'est totalement
légale mais mais simplement ça veut dire
que l'état français reconnaît la
légalité de la gpa or on ne peut pas
dire mais si vous pouvez dépenser 100
mille dollars aux états unis cela c'est
pas grave il n'y a pas de problème en
revanche c'est clairement un pas qui est
fait sur la reconnaissance de la gpa et
nous et on est sur une ambiguïté à
christian jacob qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces
enfants là q quel est le problème pour
ces enfants là ces enfants là mais on
n'a pas les fantômes ne l'a vu qu'ils
n'ont pas d'état civil vrai sens du jeu
ne soyons pas ridicule sur ce sujet
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces enfants-là ces
enfants sont en france en toute légalité
sans aucun problème
ils ont des cartes identiques à des
fonctions des cartes d'identité imaginez
ce qui est insupportable pour eux
d'avoir un passeport américain s'est
effectivement entre est sans doute très
dur à porter il faut pas sombrer dans le
ridicule simplement est un choix
politique extrêmement lourd avec des
conséquences bioéthique grave c'est à
dire qu'on s'engage vers la voie de la
légalisation de la gestation pour autrui
ce à quoi nous sommes toujours opposés
et ont fait ça encore une fois sans
consultation du comité national
d'éthique et voyez si j'ai demandé il ya
trois mois au président de la république
de consulter comité national d'éthique
c'est parce que on se doutait des
risques de bouleversements bioéthique
extrêmement grave et faire cela par voie
de circulaire
comme ces félins eh bien je trouve que
ça n'est pas digne dont christiane
taubira dis devant vous dans l'hémicycle
trois fois il n'y aura pas de gp a
autorisé en france vous ne la croyais et
je ne la crois absolument pas je ne la
crois absolument pas parce que sinon
elle ne devait pas faire cette
circulaire on ne fait pas sortir la
circulaire comme elle fait l'un parce
qu'elle sait pertinemment d'ailleurs
françois hollande l'avait dit dans sa
campagne électorale interrogé sur le
sujet il avait dit lui-même régulariser
ces situations c'est aller vers la gpa
or je suis opposé à j'espère donc
françois hollande disait clairement
qu'il était opposé à cette circulaire
donc pourquoi cette simulation mais bien
sûr c'est un reniement bien sûr que les
masques sont en train de tomber et que
le choix est celui là est d'aller vers
la gpa moi je préfère la position par
exemple patrick bloche
je suis en désaccord avec patrick bloche
sur le texte mais il aya liste il a une
position qu'elle cohérente lui dis moi
voilà je suis favorable à la gpa
il a elle c'est son choix je le respecte
je suis en désaccord total avec lui mais
je lui reconnaît le fait d'être cohérent
et et d'avoir une à la fois une une
cohérence et puis d'être dans une
honnêteté intellectuelle parfaite
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la ministre
lorsqu'elle nous répond christian jacq
quoi on va maintenant dérouler les
autres événements de la semaine mardi on
parle du droit de vote des étrangers
c'était la promesse numéro 50 du
candidat françois hollande le droit de
vote des étrangers non communautaires
aux élections locales promesses en berne
qui fait sa réapparition en ce mardi
jean marc ayrault annonce qu'il va
consulter les présidents de groupe donc
vous avant de voir s'il inclut dans la
réforme constitutionnelle de l'été
prochain il en parle à l'occasion du
bureau national du ps mathilde bérenger
jean marc ayrault le sait obtenir la
majorité des trois cinquièmes sur le
droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales ne sera pas chose
facile
le premier ministre veut donc lancé des
consultations dès la fin de cette
semaine pour vérifier l'état du rapport
de forces au parlement sur cette
question pose un souci de je vais dire
de rassemblement pour créer les
conditions d'une majorité large
je fais cette consultation et je vais
vérifier y compris sur le droit des
étrangers mais aussi sur d'autres sujets
et quand j'aurai terminé mes
consultations je pourrais faire l'état
des lieux et des rides discuté avec le
président de la république ce que ce qui
fait rassemblement est ce qu il ne le
fait pas le premier ministre était venu
s'exprimer devant le bureau national du
parti socialiste une première appelée à
se renouveler régulièrement jean marc
ayrault veut resserrer les liens avec sa
majorité et rassurer ses troupes sur des
promesses de campagne que certains
craignaient devoir enterrer s'est pas
relancé le débat s'est au contraire
sortir de ces espèces d'idées qui est en
train de s'installer comme quoi le droit
de vote on en parle tout le temps et on
faisait jamais là maintenant on va voir
m'assieds de le faire mais ça dépend pas
totalement de nouveau l'objectif des 3
5e indispensable pour une réforme
constitutionnelle sera sans aucun doute
très difficile à atteindre la majorité
devra rallier des voix dans l'opposition
largement hostile au projet
alors jean marc ayrault partir en
croisade pour une majorité des trois
cinquièmes vous allez le voir ce que
vous allez lui dire c'est peine perdue
il l'aura pas et n'a pas autre chose à
faire on est vraiment dans la diversion
alors bien entendu je vais le voir ce
que la république avait aucun problème
pour voir sur marc ayrault ça demande
quand quand ils le souhaitent
simplement on est dans une période
social économie enfin théorie chaque
jour qui passe il ya un nouveau plan
social qui qui qui tourne on voit que le
pacte de compétitivité a eu l'effet d'un
cautère sur une jambe de bois
totalement inefficace parce que
absolument pas à la mesure de ce qu'il
fallait c'est à dire baisser le coût du
travail
les textes qui sont proposés depuis le
début de l'année c'est le texte sur le
mariage des couples homosexuels
ça va être ensuite le débat sur le droit
de vote des étrangers savez ensuite un
tripatouillage électoral sans précédent
sans précédent puisque rien de moins on
nous annonce une modification du scrutin
du mode de scrutin pour les élections
cantonales
ensuite on va en faire une pour les
élections sénatoriales pour les
élections européennes
et puis la proportionnelle à l'assemblée
c'est à dire qu'on va ce gouvernement
doit discuter
jean marc ayrault attendait dans une
période de crise que nous la vivons avec
les plans sociaux qui s'accumulent les
uns aux autres
la seule préoccupation du gouvernement
c'est d'essayer de trouver des sujets de
diversion pour ne pas répondre un accord
sa sécurisation de l'emploi on va y
revenir mais attendez vous on est là on
est sur un vrai sujet mais en vrai sujet
de diversion dans cette émission là vous
n'allez pas y couper vous allez voir
jean marc ayrault sur le royaume est en
danger qu'est ce que vous allez lui dire
jamais bon c'est bien évidemment non
mais elle est aujourd'hui proposé un
compromis sur d'autres minéraux des
compromis la citoyenneté et la
nationalité sont étroitement liées en
france ce sont des principes
républicains qui sont intangibles
jouer avec ça c'est joué avec le feu
c'est ouvrir le communautarisme
parce qu'à partir du moment où on donne
le droit de vote aux étrangers
vous aurez des communautarismes qui vont
se forger et qui seront des groupes de
pression au moment des élections
municipales ou d'élections législatives
c'est vous votez pour moi si vous me
donner satisfaction sur tel ou tel sujet
on attend dé vous posez la question
encore des mois le temps d'y répondre
c'est non oui mais aussi vous dire
pourquoi parce que tout ça peut paraître
sympathique mais c'est extrêmement grave
sur les fondamentaux de notre république
donc on ne touche pas à la citoyenneté à
nationalités qui sont en france
étroitement liés et qui doivent le
rester on va sortir des assemblées pour
aller dans la rue il ya eu des
manifestations cette semaine des
salariés
goodyear psa sanofi ou encore candia
était vêtu vous voyez de tee-shirts
rouges ont manifesté aux abords du
ministère du travail dans le cortège et
bien garé jean luc mélenchon écoutez
comment le président peut tranquillement
se dire bah oui l'année prochaine ça va
être dur il y aura trois cent mille
chômeurs de plus vont mal il se rend
compte de d'encours envie déjà c'est une
loi qui doit réguler tout ça et bien sûr
bas qu'elle voulait faire d'autre c'est
où le marché où la loi bon le marché on
connaît le résultat essayant la loi
maintenant
alors voilà on en parle de l'économie le
front de gauche veut une loi contre les
licenciements financiers est ce que vous
serez avec le front de gauche elle veut
rien dire les licenciements ils sont
aussi les licenciements financiers
ce qui est important c'est qu'on a un
problème de compétitivité en france
aujourd'hui avec un coût du travail qui
est trop élevé et donc il faut baisser
ce que du travail pour retrouver des
points de compétitivité et baisser le
coût du travail
ça ne peut ça n'est pas ça ne se fait
pas comme le dit toujours monsieur
mélenchon en baissant les salaires mais
simplement en ayant d'autres clés de
répartition sur les charges
c'est la proposition que nous avons
faite avec la tva compétitivité
c'est ce que nous pouvons faire avec de
vrais accords de compétitivité qui
permettent au sein des entreprises
d'avoir de la souplesse et de pouvoir
sortir et s'affranchir du carcan des
bénéfices et françois hollande n'était
pas suffisant mais là non seulement il
est pas fille est suffisant il est
totalement inefficace a totalisé
inefficace l'accord signé entre
syndicats et patronat parce que cet
accord on va là encore il est pas encore
arrivé cet accord on va la voir dans les
semaines qui viennent sur la table moi
je crois que cet accord va dans le va
dans le bon sens simplement il n'est
absolument pas au niveau pour répondre à
la situation à laquelle nous avons à
faire face mais il va plutôt dans le bon
sens et à partir du moment se poser tel
quel à la torture oui moi je suis ainsi
on va voir quand le texte va nous
arriver je vais recevoir les
organisations syndicales donc je reçois
les leader de fo de la cfdt également
enfin de l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux sans doute la cgt je suis par
principe la cgt refuse toujours nous
rencontrer mais bon bref essentielle si
les autres organisations syndicales
viennent on aura ce débat avec eux mais
moi je suis plutôt dans un
esprit positif quand même un texte kinky
à rire l'assemblée qui vous convient
dans l'est dans ce calendrier
parlementaire jusqu'à jouer
oui parce qu'on n'est pas obtus à partir
du moment où ça va dans le bon sens et
que les les partenaires sociaux ont
trouvé un point d'accord simplement je
trouve que ça n'est pas suffisant et ça
ne répond en aucun cas ce n'est pas au
niveau de la réponse apportée mais à
partir du moment où il va dans le bon
sens
ceci est en attendant d'avoir reçu les
partenaires sociaux et puis d'avoir vu
le texte
allez on va passer au mercredi tient une
réunion des fillonistes y avait
longtemps
et oui le r ump déjà de la vieille
histoire cette dissidence parlementaires
de l'ump qui s'est dissout de début
janvier
et pourtant françois fillon continue à
rassembler ses députés à l'assemblée
rencontre très discrète mardi cam mardi
matin sans caméra avec une seule photo
celle ci twitté par lionel tardy
de quoi at on parlé réponse d'un député
fillonniste à la sortie beaucoup de
parlementaires députés et sénateurs
fillon
donc
ce mythe avec l'emploi des scuds
souhaite faire
on peut lui aussi à l'intérieur de l'ump
notamment de peser sur la réflexion
adecco
recomposé pour la posture est célèbre
le gros communisme
ah oui oui mais on peut quand même se
réunir jeudi
heureusement au bureau politique ce
matin de l'ump je suis allé à la réunion
autour de françois fillon parce que
françois fillon
c'est au fond probablement aujourd'hui
dans les politiques actifs
c'est celui qui a le plus à dire aux
français en terme de fonds et en termes
de propositions bon 120 députés présents
à cette réunion françois fillon tort non
non non non non personnes 120 personnes
député 120 personnes
non on les compte pas simplement les jdc
aussi le président de groupe pour
principe les députés lui parle dans quel
monde y voit une réunion les 10 ans en
venant de cassation entend faire de
grave moi vous êtes vous étiez est un
très proche de jean françois copé vous
êtes sûr que vous êtes une famille très
unie attendus ce qui serait pas normal
c'est que françois fillon parle pas avec
les parlementaires
mais il ya toujours mais c'est pas son
groupe de filles nice non non c'est pas
son groupe il n'y a pas de groupe de
définir simplement ils voient comme jean
françois copé le fait et comme chaque
jour vous avez des parlementaires qui
réunissent quelques collègues
parlementaires simplement ils ont
peut-être moins de notoriété françois
fillon jean françois copé donc on en
parle moins mais tout ça est tout à fait
normal est plutôt sain dans la vie d'un
parti politique ça ne vous inquiète pas
non seulement ce mac est pas mais je
veux que c'est plutôt bien que les gens
se parlent entre eux par affinités
question jacob septembre prochain
l'élection c'est sûr pour l'ump pour le
nouveau président de l'ump où comme le
dit thierry mariani au très favorable à
repousser cette élection à 2014
après les municipales ou encore plus
loin moi je pense qu'il faut respecter
les termes de l'accord il ya un accord
qui était passée qui a prévu des
élections au mois de septembre
moi je suis assez attaché à ce que l'on
respecte les engagements qui en direct
rien
voilà c'est parce qu'il a finalement
tout le monde y trouve son compte les
fillonnistes ont des postes à
responsabilité au sein du parti jean
françois copé le patron est ce que
réellement vous sentez une envie d'aller
vers ces élections ils vont coûter cher
qui sont peut-être pas bonne pour
l'image et la démocratie a toujours un
coup et je pense que l'engagement a été
pris d'une élection en septembre et
qu'il faut respecter cet engagement
fatigue du moins c'est mon point de vue
après bon
subi c'est quand même un petit peu cette
décision voilà il faut bien le faire
parce qu'on a dit qu'on le ferait non
mais c'est que partir du moment où on
était en dessous une situation de crise
qui n'a échappé à personne ça a été les
moments difficiles à vivre
c'était difficile de s'en sortir on s'en
est sorti et plutôt bien avec un groupe
qui est réunifiée avec au parti des
équipes très paritaire et avec
l'engagement qui est ces élections au
mois deux mois de septembre donc voila
moi je pense que et dans la vie faut pas
cherché à compliquer les choses il faut
respecter les engagements et voulait
créer un tout petit peu ces élections
comme ça recommence que ça recommence et
absolument pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous dis qu'il faut tenir
des engagements d'oracle et chrome bah
non parce que si je le craignais je le
dirai qu'il faut pas tenir les
engagements qu'il faut en prendre
d'autres
je pense que vous savez pourquoi
compliquer les choses lorsqu'elles sont
simples lorsqu'elles sont écrites donc
voilà c'est la position qui est la
mienne
peut-être d'autres avril mai mais en
tout cas je défends des fois mis en
attente et une envie du côté de françois
fillon d'y aller ou pas voulu parler
faisant temps oui bien sûr parle souvent
mais voilà je sais pas écoutez c'est à
lui de s'exprimer là dessus on a
souhaité moi j'ai souhaité j'ai fait
partie des artisans de cet accord sur ce
point que l'élection ait lieu en
septembre
parce que je ne voulais en aucun cas que
nous soyons une élection où nous ayons
une élection en pleine session
parlementaire
il ya le temps du parlement du travail
parlementaire et j'entends que pendant
ce temps les parlementaires soient
mobilisés sur leur travail de député
donc élections en septembre ce qui
permet d'avoir une campagne en juillet
août et donc d'avoir les candidats qui
annoncent leur candidature
avant le mois de juillet à la fin de
faim pendant les pénalités ce qui nous
permet d'avoir une session parlementaire
qui se déroule en dehors de la campagne
électorale était le socle de l'électorat
de françois hollande
en avril dernier on va passer
aujourd'hui on va parler des
fonctionnaires c'est effectivement le
socle de françois hollande son électorat
les fonctionnaires six mois plus tard
descendre dans la rue
plus de cent mille personnes défilent
dans les principales villes de france à
paris ses rimes benameur qui s'est
jointe au cortège
un avertissement au gouvernement
voilà comment les fonctionnaires
qualifie cette journée de grève
ici plusieurs milliers de personnes dans
le cortège parisien parti de port royal
parmi eux corinne agents à pôle emploi
ils protestent contre la dégradation de
ses conditions de travail
les problématiques aux rencontres c'est
pour ça que je suis dans la rue
aujourd'hui c'est des problèmes de
salaires et des problèmes d'effectif on
est actuellement sur pour l'emploi tout
le monde le sait en déficit d'effectif
pour arriver à traiter la masse de
chômeurs quand on inscrit cinq millions
de fonctionnaires étaient appelés à la
grève par trois syndicats cgt fsu et
solidaires
une première depuis la victoire de
françois hollande nous avons subi des
dégradations énorme sous le précédent
gouvernement sarkozy maintenant les
agents de la fonction publique
attendre que le nouveau gouvernement
revienne et mettre en place de nouvelles
dispositions
leurs revendications une amélioration de
leurs salaires et de leurs conditions de
travail en désaccord
la décision importante de recréer des
postes en particulier l'éducation
nationale mais ça ne suffit pas et les
agents des autres secteurs sont
extrêmement préoccupé il attendre un an
maintenant des gestes urgents sur les
salaires sur le jour de carence et sur
l'emploi les syndicats sont en pleine
négociation avec la ministre de la
fonction publique
marylise lebranchu a reconnu une
situation difficile pour les
fonctionnaires mais rappelle les
contraintes budgétaires
elle doit faire des propositions
concrètes sur les conditions de travail
le 7 février
les syndicats ont prévenu la
mobilisation sera plus massive
s'ils n'obtiennent pas des avancées
alors là on peut dire que tous les
gouvernements quels que soient les
majorités se heurte à ces mêmes
revendications des fonctionnaires
il ya des négociations qui commencent
jeudi prochain avec la ministre de la
fonction publique est ce qu'il faut
tenir bon sur le jour de carence et
surtout sur le point d indice sur le
jour de carence oui en revanche ce qui
m'inquiète est ce que j'ai entendu des
déclarations de madame lebranchu c'est
de revenir sur la rémunération au mérite
et je pense que ça ce serait une vraie
erreur je l' ai mis en place j'étais le
ministre de la fonction publique qui a
mis en place la rémunération au mérite
ce qui permet de corriger le régime
indemnitaire selon des critères qui sont
définies avec avec les partenaires et
donc de valoriser les déroulements de
carrière d'agent ce qu'on a beaucoup
d'agents dans la fonction publique qui
arrivent au bout de leurs grilles
indiciaires et qui se retrouve au bout
de 20 ans d'activité sans plus aucune
perspective est donc là il faut savoir
redonner un coup de pouce de la même
façon qu'on l'avait fait avec le un sur
deux le un sur deux ça permet de
fonctionnaires sur douala le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
ç'a permis par exemple dans l'éducation
nationale pour les jeunes enseignants
d'avoir une augmentation très importante
de leur rémunération dans les premières
années d'enseignement et jeux pour les
fonctionnaires pour moi lorsque je les
mis en place je l'aï mis en place sur
les cadres à l'époque et je les fais en
parfait accord avec les organisations
ont défini les critères ensemble mais
vous avez beaucoup d'agents dans la
fonction publique qui aujourd'hui sont
insuffisamment payés et donc le salaire
la rémunération au mérite permet de
favoriser ceux qui sont très engagés sur
leur travail et sont des critères que
l'on définit avec les partenaires vous
avez connu les manifestations de
fonctionnaires dans la rue sous gestion
cause il ya aussi le premier premier le
le premier ministre la fonction publique
après je crois 12 13 ans où il n'y avait
pas eu d'accord de signer en fonction
publique a signé le premier accord a
capté un manifestant vous les voyez
encore sous françois hollande sait qu'il
ne doit pas y avoir beaucoup de
différence entre la politique de nicolas
sarkozy et celle de françois hollande
s'ils sont encore dans la rue en tout
cas il ya beaucoup de déception puisque
l on était trois fois plus par la gauche
elle est là la gauche a toujours trompé
les fonctionnaires de réellement la
rémunération au mérite est une bonne
chose il faut la maintenir
de mon point de vue il faut maintenir le
non remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur
deux ce qui permet dans un certain
nombre de secteurs de pouvoir renvoyer à
augmenter la rémunération sur le
principe du un sur deux sait que les
économies ont été faites sur les
salaires pour la moitié sont reversés
permettent les augmentations de
rémunérations donc c'était ça aussi
d'où l'action du point d'indicé pour
l'instant non non non mais ça bon à la
ministre de de négocier pour moi les
deux points importants c'est elle a sur
2 et surtout de maintenir la
rémunération au mérite alors on va finir
cette émission et je voudrais vous
proposer c'est un peu l'image de la
semaine cette surprise on est au delà de
la politique mais on a besoin d'avoir
votre avis david beckham entre le people
le sport 37 ans ici au paris
saint-germain l'anglais qui arrive au
paris saint germain
est-ce que
vous voyez dans cette arrivée de ce
joueur bien au delà du sport on le
disait que parce que ce côté people
c'est quoi c'est le qatar tout puissant
qui arrive en france
non ce n'est pas le cas à moi je
répondrai pas sous cet angle là je pense
que c'est une opération cette bonne
opération de com c'est sympathique mais
à partir du ce et du marketing
effectivement mais à partir du moment où
l'évolution du dos de nos clubs de foot
fait que si on veut exister là aussi sur
la scène internationale les clubs de
foot sont de grosses entreprises et le
marketing
ben il ya obligatoirement sa place mais
on a besoin de vivre avec ton donc ces
groupes on va pas jouer les vierges
effarouchées sur le sujet c'est un coût
de 5 ou deux comme c'est un coup de
marketing qui semble plutôt réussi
voilà projecteur sur la france oui je
sais pas si c'est une bonne ou mauvaise
nouvelle mais à mon avis bon voilà ça
fait partie des choses et le un grand
club comme le psg ne peux pas je veux
dire on ne peut pas être en retard ou ne
pas être dans la course des grands clubs
internationaux et bon voilà une
marketing en fait partie le marketing
fait partie de ça lewenza femmes merci
beaucoup qui surgit comme d'avoir
participé à notre émission merci on se
retrouve